على هذه اللوحه كتب السوريون سيرحلون
والقرار التخم
قرار يبدو ان المعارضه التركيه ليست وحدها
من انفردت به بل الحزب الحاكم ايضا قرار
اصبح اشبه بسباق مع الزمن شماعته اللاجئون
السوريون
فوافقا لوزير الخارجيه التركي مولود شاو
شوغلو فان تركيا قررت انشاء لجنه اعداد
خارطه طريق لتطبيع العلاقات بين تركيا
وسوريا احد اهدافها اعاده اللاجئين الذين
وصلوا الى تركيا من مناطق سيطره النظام
الى تلك المناطق اللجنه وفقا لشاوش اوغلو
ستضم ممثلين عن روسيا وايران وتركيا
وسوريا وستعمل على وضع خارطه طريق للتطبيق
اضافه لتشكيل لجنه خاصه بملف عوده
اللاجئين يعقبها اجراء مفاوضات لاعاده
السوريين ممن قدموا من المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها الحكومه السوريه
قبل ايام من الحسم الرئاسي حسب المتنافسون
تحالفاتهم ومواقفهم تحالفات تقول الانباء
ان هدفها الابرز هو ترحيل سوري
فوفقا للتحالفات الجديده جميعها متفقه على
ترحيل السوريين من اقصى اليمين حزب الظفر
بقياده اوميت اوزدا واشد المعادين
للمهاجرين واللاجئين اعلن دعمه لمنافس
اردوغان كما الكليج دار اوغلو بينما اعلن
سنان اوغن القومي المتشدد والمناهض لوجود
اللاجئين في تركيا دعم اردوغان في المرحله
المقبله وبين هذا وذاك ليس من المعلوم من
سيحسم السباق القادم لكن الاكيد ان الجميع
اتفقوا على ترحيل السوري
حتى من وعد بغير ذلك رائد المصطفى العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات